hello frog
my name is anam zola and i'm going to
hack your peloton
i'm not thinking a lot on zola hacking
somebody's peloton just making it go
really fast and then like they fall off
that would be funny i mean it wouldn't
be funny they got hurt but like it'd be
funny to see it happen it'd be like a
fail video or something like that anyway
what's going on guys and apparently it's
basically confirmed now
toby maguire
is gonna be in doctor strange too right
i guess kevin feige and marvel studios
haven't officially said that but
literally everybody's like yeah man it's
happening andrew garfield is the
question now a lot of people are like is
andrew garfield going to show up in this
movie here's the funny thing it makes
perfect sense that toby maguire would be
in this movie and i and i have been look
here's here's i've been saying this
about doctor trains too i've been saying
this about dreams too and some of you
guys have been thinking i was lying
right and i'm i'm angry
some of you guys
i'm angry right now
some of you guys
thought i was lying now here's the thing
for real over true uh with doctor
strange two the the big kind of though
the way it's been build by like sam
raimi and all those guys has basically
been like it's gonna be a game changer
for the mcu and i have been saying this
over and over and over and over again
doctor strange two is going to lead to a
consolidation of the multiverse and
basically all the properties that belong
to fox and whatever property sony wants
to bring in and of course the the
properties that the marvel cinematic
universe has they're all going to end up
combining together it's a great way for
the mcu to bring back characters that
otherwise have basically been removed so
like if they want to bring back red
skull for example and say he's not just
some disembodied dude who's sitting out
there guarding the soul stone and that
we were all kind of disappointed because
we were really hoping that steve rogers
would see him again which would have
made for a really cool scene when steve
rogers like i can't believe you're alive
and red skull's like i can't believe
you're alive either man dick like i mean
it's one of those things we always
wanted to see
right but nonetheless it's a way for
them to basically consolidate all that
stuff and bring it bring it all back
together if they want to reintroduce
iron man albeit without robert downey jr
which i don't know how fans would be
receptive to they could do that if they
wanted to bring back thanos they could
do that if they want to introduce whole
new heroes they can do that i mean there
is the screenshot out there of
apparently the credits scene with like
all the people who are appearing in the
movie which includes like hyperion and
stuff like that i don't believe a word
of it but it would be cool if it
happened right like apparently henry
cavill's playing hyperion which would be
hilarious well you guys don't know who
that is hyperion is the closest thing
marvel has to superman like marcus
milton from earth what is it 13034 he's
basically superman by all standards of
measurement the closest thing he got to
that was sun god during jonathan
hickman's avengers new avengers but like
it'd be hilarious if henry cavill comes
to the mcu he plays hyperion and
everybody was like yeah man the mcu
makes a better superman than warner
brothers
it does be hilarious but here's here's
here's a cool thing right here's a cool
thing behind all this having toby
mcguire in doctor strange too makes the
most sense it makes the absolute most
sense and for a couple different reasons
the the first one is sam raimi's making
doctor strange too sam raimi made the
original spider-man if the question was
asked to him hey man you get to have one
version of the spy of spider-man brought
to dr strange too which one do you want
of course you would pick toby right sam
raimi and toby maguire spider-man go
hand in hand the other reason is why
spider-man is apparently going to be in
doctor strange too now this is the part
that's a little bit of of rumor although
i think confirmations are basically
slowly coming out here the idea is that
somewhere along the line of the film
he's gonna fight the scarlet witch now
here's the funny thing about this right
i know i know a lot of you guys are just
like oh my man this this would be so
cool but like he would get crushed what
he though here's the important thing to
understand about toby maguire's
spider-man one he's the most experienced
out of all the spider-man right out of
tom holland and andrew garfield toby has
been spider-man the longest right he's
he's like your granddad's spider-man
right i mean you know like even when he
came through the portal and spider-man
no way home sure he was calm right which
honestly i kind of wish there had been a
little more hype while he just kind of
standing there and he was like what's up
young whip snap
like he just kind of came in and it's
like i mean i would have hoped for a
little more grandeur right a little more
pomp and circumstance andrew garfield's
interest was amazing oh my god dude i
still get goosebumps when i watch it
this is just
[Music]
man it's it's one of those it's just one
of those things right it's just it's
like the fan reactions and everything
it's just it's so phenomenal but with
tony mcguire being more experienced the
most important thing to take away from
that is not how he approaches situations
it's not how he approaches conflicts and
fights it's the development of his
spider sense so when it comes to mobile
comics the only reason spider-man ever
does as well as he does is because of
his spider-sense remove the spider-sense
from peter parker right take take the
spider-sense away from peter parker what
is he he's a really smart kid that can
punch hard and climb up walls and that's
it right but like
virtually anybody could trash him right
like venom would be able to destroy
spider-man like his stories would not be
very lengthy at all his spider sense is
what saves him nine times out of ten now
a spider sense is not perfect right so
if somebody were to like attack him he
would know that he's in danger and he
might know the general direction of
where that danger is coming from but he
wouldn't know the details of it but
that's changed over the years if
spider-man spider sense has been
expanded on and become more adept you
would have to believe that would apply
to toby maguire there were multiple
instances in the tobii maguire
spider-man films where his spider sense
had seemed to be refined to the point
especially when you get to spider-man 3
where he could actually determine the
location of where the danger was coming
from and react accordingly now imagine
20 years has passed
right if we treat toby mcguire's
spider-man the way it was seemingly
treated in spider-man no way home that
20 years has actually passed since the
third spider-man movie and the time he
was brought back in spider-man no way
home we have to believe it's 20 years
worth of improvement regarding his
spider-sense it's ridiculously
fine-tuned you compare that to andrew
garfield who had only been spider-man
for about five years you compare it to
tom holland spider-man who had only been
spider-man for less time than that so
it's one of those things where like toby
is more adept now what does that mean in
relation to scarlet witch could he beat
scarlet witch no it's
ridiculous to believe otherwise like he
would not be able to beat scottie witch
he would just
stand a better chance but then once you
start adding cards to this deck right
once you start adding different players
in then suddenly spider-man becomes
incredibly important and that's one of
the things that's so cool about this
right over the years in comics
spider-man has been depicted in
different ways when it comes to his
intelligence he's kind of capable
sometimes he's not whatever one of the
best ways his intelligence was depicted
was during dan slot spider-man run
during big time when there was like a
bomb that was going to go off or
something like that and nobody else
could figure out how to disarm it and
peter parker figured it out that's the
important thing is that when you take
into account toby mcguire's spider-sense
you take into account anything that's
remotely close to you to an adaptation
of how his fighter sense has progressed
in the comics into the movie and then
you add his intelligence into the movie
then what you have here is a guy who
while he's not the most powerful he's a
guy you need i mean if we had people
like black panther or we had adam
brashear or even like doctor doom or
something like that it would make all
the difference in the world but we don't
right unfortunately we lost chadwick
boseman so we don't have t'challa and
there's probably nobody else as smart as
t'challa is reed is supposed to be in
the movie but apparently he's part of
the illuminati so it wouldn't really
look like he'd be working on behalf of
doctor strange or anything like that one
of the things we've been talking about
here is basically the multiversal
avengers which has more or less been
confirmed right like we said that months
ago with like doctor strange too like
what was it like six months ago we were
just like we're getting the multiversal
avengers right like there's no way
that's not gonna happen when they first
started giving us little bits of
information about doctor strange too and
when we first started making videos here
about doctor strange two it was like
multiversal avengers calling it now
right that's exactly what's happening
having spider-man on that team right
let's give ourselves a kind of general
roster here even if we don't have an
absolute depiction right you got doctor
strange there's your magic side you've
got america chavez there's your ability
to jump through portals right to give
you basically access ports escape
hatches different things like that into
other realities you got peter parker
who's basically your brains and then the
spider sins can also make him aware of
when attacks are coming other people can
piggyback off his spider sense to know
if they're basically an imminent danger
but it's one of those things where
everybody gather around right and
spider-man's wearing a shirt right like
i've got a spider sense if you see me
running try to keep up right that kind
of a thing so it's it's you have
different characters that could offer
something there how many spider-man
there makes the most sense toby mcguire
would be the best person to add to that
list he's got the experience he's got
the intelligence plus it would just be
cool to see now again whether or not we
get andrew garfield i don't know that's
one of the big things about doctor
strange too i think if we do end up
seeing andrew garfield there's going to
be just like some multiversal hopping
like hopping and skipping around
different universes things along those
lines which may very well lead to us
getting andrew garfield or seeing him in
some kind of cameo capacity but i have a
hard time believing with the way
spider-man no way home ended the fan
reception to it the fact that we were
all so hyped about seeing andrew and
seeing toby that that's the last we're
ever going to see of them in any
meaningful capacity right that like dr
strange is going to walk into the
universe where andrew garfield is and
andrew garfield is like making pancakes
and dr strange's like oh my bad man and
andrew's like nah it's cool and then
like he leaves i doubt that'll be the
case right i think it'll be an actual
meaningful appearance what the depth is
i don't know but as far as tobey maguire
goes i think he's a member of the
multiversal avengers he's one of the
different superheroes doctor strange is
banding together for the purpose of
either defeating schumachorath fighting
scarlet witch fading facing off against
whoever like the main threat happens to
be or one of the threats who were out
there but with that being said guys let
me know what you think down in the
comments section right let me know how
excited you are about this idea of toby
maguire being in doctor strange too and
him fighting scarlet witch right let me
know i mean here's another question
right do you think he's gonna be like
listen wanda we've all been through
things i have struggled i lost my uncle
ben i understand the pain of losing
someone you love right and then like he
puts his hand on her shoulder and she
slowly breaks down and then gives him a
hug and he pats her on the back and says
it'll be okay and then one is like i've
seen the error of my ways time to ally
with toby mcguire and doctor strange and
then doctor straight and then like then
like the montage music starts
[Music]
push it to the limit and like they all
go walking up to where like evil doctor
strange is and he's just like my god you
know it's like yeah
the fight's over son it's done you're
done son this victory is guaranteed i
don't know if it would be something like
that it would be cool i kind of want to
hear them play push it to the limit
somewhere during the movie i don't care
where it is just somewhere over the
course of the movie
push it to the limits
walk along the razor's edge don't look
back just keep your head or you'll be
finished
open up the limit i'm just saying i
think it would be cool if they played
that song somewhere over the course of
the movie i'm i'm sorry i'm so excited
people i'm just i'm really excited i'm
going to the royal rumble this weekend
so like i'm really really excited to go
there and see that but let me know you
guys think down in the comments section
for real and for true let me know how
excited you are about the idea of seeing
toby mcguire in doctor strange too and
do you think we'll see andrew i don't
know if we'll really see tom as i
understand it he's still kind of on the
fence and he felt like like spider-man
no way home was just a great place to
end it
i guess the movie ended with it
basically being an origin story and then
he's gonna kind of kind of continue on
and be spiderman it's not like he died
so i don't really know if that's a good
place to end it but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments thank
you all for watching
this is enough rambling and nonsense
from me and i will catch you all later
peace